okay if you're just joining us here on
al jazeera we are bringing you
uh that uh continuing coverage of that
attack in a church in
nice three people have been killed in a
stabbing
attack the uh the attacker has
been taken into custody we're also
learning of an incidence in the french
city of avignon police say they've shot
dead a man after he threatens
members of the public with a knife we're
also hearing that a man has been
arrested in
jeddah in saudi arabia after stabbing a
guard at the french
consulate there that's according to
state's
television so that's three separate
incidents
in just one day let's speak now to
yasuluati he's the head of the justice
and liberties for all committee
and as a civil liberties activist good
to have you with us
here on al jazeera i've just listed
three
separate incidents um and in all of
those incidents the
the attacker has been shouting god is
great
um assuming a mantle of islam there
what's your reaction to that
well my first reaction is a set of
questions to to which
so far we have no answers so we are
unsafe in churches
restaurants concert halls early
transportation
and the list goes on now we are in a
country that has implemented mass
surveillance
the government said we need to monitor
all conversations on the internet
we need to be able to predict terrorist
attacks we need
extra means for the state to prosecute
any person preventive justice
to put people under house arrest ahead
of
the the time they need to act and yet
this is happening again
just one week after the the beheading of
samuel patty what's going on with this
country's counter-terrorism legislation
and this country's counter-terrorism
strategy so to quote again
the domestic intelligence themselves the
repression-based model is a complete
failure
i can bring you here this book from
versailles
40 years of failed counter-terrorism and
yet we're not asking ourselves
why is this happening to us and why this
keeps happening again
and again and again so what are we going
to do now just stay at home and don't go
out and just do nothing about it
this is these are really serious
questions and the government
yet again will fail to address this
question by saying
what is not working within the
counter-terrorism
framework that makes these attacks
happening again and again
so is it is this a failure on behalf of
the the the
francis police and counter-terrorism
then why do you think this is happening
why do you think people are picking up
knives and running into churches and and
killing people well the why so far
nobody is answering
because they keep killing these people
when are we going to already these
people interrogate them on their
motivations
when are we going to able to act ahead
of time and prevent these attacks from
happening
i mean a woman was beheaded inside a
church that means these people have
nothing sacred
there is nothing there are no more you
know boundaries for them
and this has happened there's again one
week after a teacher was beheaded
so now the friendship needs to it needs
to really address these questions and
say
where have we failed and why are these
people are people attacking us
now a church you know saw this beheading
today
750 people got killed in mosques across
the muslim world
why can't we connect the dots and see
that this ideology has been spread
and that we lost so far the battle of
idea because these are again
these keep happening again and again and
we keep
uh dealing with these these attacks
separate from one another
they are not apparently and as you just
mentioned it three attacks happen today
so how many how many more attacks before
we start questioning our strategy
apparently it's not working what are
they going to do now blame muslims again
tell them you are responsible
because a man did that like it happened
in knees and after samuel patti for
example
honestly this is really a disaster for
france really a disaster and for us
we are truly asking the government when
are you going to start asking serious
questions
and start beating around the booth when
it comes to a failed counter-terrorism
strategy
so so when it comes to to trying to find
out the motivation
behind this you said yourself these
attackers clearly hold nothing sacred
we understand that the attacker in nice
has been taken
into custody we know one of the
individuals behind the bataclan attack
he was taken into custody but refused to
talk so so what would you suggest the
the governments and investigators do in
this instance what would you see as a
step forward to understanding why people
go to these lengths
to kill others well so far the
government has plenty of means
to investigate on this individual
interrogating him
tracking all his communications for the
past year to say the least
the same thing happened with samuel
patti's you know assassin
he was reported multiple times and the
government failed to address
these multiple reports so now the state
has won the battle
against human rights and civil liberties
and their right for privacy now maybe
maybe they have the means to find out
what happened and we know
these measures that have been
implemented did not prevent these
attacks
and now it's on the government to
literally interrogate this person
and maybe connect the dots between the
attacks in the non-muslim world and the
attacks in the muslim world
because again we see that mosques have
been attacked multiple times in egypt
alone
over 300 people got killed in a mosque
in the sinai region
and nobody made the connection today
what is what was happening in this
church
to defend the french president he's not
responsible for attacks that happened in
egypt's mosque still
in terms of how france addresses this
and and what france should be doing
moving is responsible no the problem is
that we we
take attacks at home and don't connect
them with what's happening abroad
the ideology behind these attacks is the
same and at the same time we
have you know daesh i keep saying it
over and over again these attacks when
they carry them shouting allah akbar
they know exactly what they are doing
refer madam to their peace the
destruction of the grey zone we want to
shed blood
and turn oppression against muslims and
these governments from macron francois
and sarkozy et cetera they all did
exactly that
they don't address the why and how of
these attacks and then look for a
scapegoat
to divert public scrutiny from the from
the failures i'm gonna quote again
john brennan we can't call him an islam
leftist
he said in 2015 the attacks in paris are
a massive intelligence failure
we could have learned from that yet we
haven't and we have plenty of
documentation saying that
40 years of counter-terrorism in france
have failed
do you think that honestly sorry i'm
sorry to cut you off
do you think that the the french
counter-terrorism is overstretched then
do you think that they are
perhaps monitoring too many people or
they aren't monitoring the individuals
they should be
what what should the counter-terrorism
forces be doing if they have all these
tools available why are they missing the
most dangerous individuals
two problems rose under nicolas sarkozy
first he destroyed
the national network of domestic
intelligence what we call
the general intelligence le hansen
general
he destroyed that and after we uh
rebuilding the so-called national
intelligence for the dcra
two clans emerged the the the new clans
under sarkozy
and their previous ones and the second
problem again
is that this intelligence is getting way
too much information with this mass
surveillance
they can't possibly process everything
so they said in 2014 2015
despite the snowden revelations that we
need to monitor everybody
sir you can't monitor everybody's you
know details and monitor
and then process them there's way too
much information so they put the whole
country under mass surveillance and
they're unable to process the
information they're getting
and the example has been given a week
ago with samuel patti
people reported the men and jair dharma
when he was asking the national assembly
refuses the question we have a system
called pharaohs
to which people can report and then
report you know accounts
that are showing radical behavior that
dangerous one it has
it happened multiple times including by
muslims this time again
mass surveillance failed again is
because the state is getting way too
much information
domestic intelligence is a mess clans
are fighting one another
agencies are not working with one
another and what was being put under the
shed light in in
under under the lights uh in uh after 9
11
that agencies were rivaled to one
another not sharing information etc it's
happening again in france
so how many more lives before we start
asking the real questions madam
and this person i'm afraid i said five
years ago these terrorist attacks are
the new norm
i couldn't even imagine that this would
take place in the church
i mean like i have you know a son who
just wanna take transportation
honestly this is a disaster and i fear
for the month to come for france
okay yes sir the watsi they're joining
us by skype thank you very much indeed
for your thoughts and your analysis well
early